it's time for audience questions first
one is from Bev Bev says hey David other
than impeachment and the 25th amendment
should there be more ways to remove
high-ranking officials including the
president I have an answer that is not
an exact answer to the question so
should there be more ways to remove a
high-ranking official including the
president I think the answer is no I
think we actually already have enough
ways to do it with a president you've
got impeachment you've got the 25th
amendment with members of the House you
already have elections every two years
right it's almost like a recall every
two years and I know the power of
incumbency and money in politics but
those are other issues that we have to
deal with so I don't think we need more
means with which we can remove elected
officials I just think that the means we
have should be easier to use and what I
mean by that is when you consider the
power of incumbency when you consider
the difficulty of impeaching a president
we just want to make sure that the
methods we have our real methods just
having it written into the Constitution
that there is a 25th amendment unless
it's practically speaking useable it's
not actually that useful to have it
there so I would not be against as some
people talk bad about we should have the
ability an easier ability to recall a
president at any time and do a recall
election I don't really think so I mean
for it four-year terms aren't so long
and we do have other means but we want
to make sure that those other means can
be used Senate of terms are six years
yes six years is quite a bit of time but
there are other means for removing
senators for wrongdoing yeah and in the
house again it's every two years so I
don't think we need more methods I think
we got to make sure that the methods we
have can actually be used so on the
presidential level I feel as though if
you are elected then you're entitled to
serve out those four years barring that
you don't commit any high crimes treason
the things that we're all aware of yeah
because the public doesn't know what
they're getting themselves into that
they're going to get a certain amount of
time out of this presidency they know
how long it's going to be and as long as
they won the
and justly they should be able to serve
that out unless there is some big
scandal that extenuating where you know
it's possible that in 2010 if it was
easy let's say for example you could do
a recall election of a president at
every midterm right so 2008 Obama is
elected 2010 you can do a recall Obama
might have been removed from office 2010
I mean it was not a good midterm in 2010
you had the tea party you had earlier
still in the recovery from the Great
Recession although it was clearly
recovering at that time you could have
had President Obama removed from office
in 2010 if we had something like that
ending up serving two years instead of
eight and I think we can all agree
particularly in the context of Trump
that that would have not been a very
good thing and I think it would be a
danger to the stability of our democracy
if we were able to just recall the
president over some minor political
issue that we disagreed with him on I
mean like if Republicans and you know
the majority at the time of Americans
wanted to impeach obama over obamacare
we would look back and think that was
silly it's not like we were talking
about some you know the Teapot Dome
scandal with watergate scandal
yeah this new russia scandal that that
seems mildly insignificant he could have
been removed for wearing a tan suit on a
day when he talked about serious things
yeah okay so I think that no we don't
need more mechanisms for the removal of
politicians we need to responsibly be
able to use the ones that we have